tell the truth about the war on your
social networks on tv support us in any
way you can any but not silence and then
peace will come ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky speaks out during the
2022 grammy awards our children draw
swooping rockets not shooting stars over
400 children have been injured and 153
children died and will never see them
drawing during sunday's broadcast the
politician made a surprise appearance
sending his thanks to everyone who has
shown support as the country continues
to battle the ongoing russian invasion
our parents are happy to wake up in the
morning in bomb shelters but alive
our loved ones don't know if we will be
together again zilinski who was a
comedian and actor before winning the
presidency in 2019 appeared via a
pre-taped message during the ceremony he
introduced a performance by john legend
by urging viewers to use music to create
change the word doesn't let us choose
whose it was and who stays in internal
silence our musicians wear body armor
instead of tuxedo they sing to the
wounded in hospitals even to those who
can't hear them but the music will break
through anyway we defend our freedom to
live to love to sound on our land we are
fighting russia which brings horrible
silence with its bombs the death silence
fill the silence with your music feel it
today to tell our story that's when
legend honored ukraine with a
performance of his new song free
way down moses
go down the egypt land
russia invaded ukraine last month and
ever since stars have rallied support
for the country ashton kutcher and mila
kunis have raised more than 30 million
dollars to support ukraine maxim
schmierkovsky went to poland to help
refugees and bethany frankel's b-strong
initiative has raised 100 million
dollars and counting it's massive
it's extraordinary it involves now three
different prongs one is
extracting people from ukraine many of
whom are orphans we're distributing aid
within ukraine and then we have a
warehouse in hungary and in poland this
is
really a massive effort and we have been
raising
almost a million dollars a day we were
the first there and we have a really
major infrastructure so it's it's sad to
say it's going well because it's not a
great situation but it's going well and
at the academy awards last sunday actors
like jamie lee curtis walked to the red
carpet wearing a blue ribbon reading
with refugees i just want to represent
the refugee crisis
let people
wake up and realize that this is a
humanitarian crisis the refugee crisis
is very real the displaced people are
very real
and they need help they need homes and
they need support
and there are oscar-nominated films flee
and kanto
which is which are about displaced
people so it's important meanwhile jason
mamoa and benedict cumberbatch showed
their support with a blue and yellow
pocket square and ukrainian flag pin
you're that's representing for the
ukraine how important is it to support
the ukraine
100
yeah all the glory of the ukraine
[Music]